the victims of Friday's London Bridge
attack are being honored today with the
vigil the tribute to Jack Merritt and
Saskia Jones included a rare joint
appearance by British Prime Minister
Boris Johnson an opposition Labour Party
leader Jeremy Corbyn who was you know in
a fierce election fight Roxana Saberi is
near London Bridge with more on this
story good morning to you Roxana what's
happening there right now a good morning
Gail well London Bridge is open again
this morning but the case is far from
closed the attacker was a convicted
terrorist who was supposed to be
monitored by the authorities now many
people here are asking why they weren't
aware that he's still posted danger
armed with a fire extinguisher and an
ornamental whale tusks
these brave bystanders tackled osman
khan and helped detain him long enough
for police to arrive the officers then
shot and killed him Khan turned out to
be wearing what police described as a
hoax suicide vest
Toby Williamson says his colleagues
helped fend Khan off when he launched
his attack in a nearby building got any
choice it's in your face it's right
there and I just hope that we can all do
the right thing in those moments I
despite these words in 2008 Khan was
arrested two years later for taking part
in a plot to blow up London Stock
Exchange he was sentenced to 16 years in
prison but released early on probation
last year on Friday he was attending a
conference for rehabilitating prisoners
when his killing spree began his victims
23 year old Saskia Jones and 25 year old
Jack Merritt were part of the group that
organized the conference Amir Eden was
walking nearby when the attacker ran on
to London Bridge
I was thinking please please let this
not be like June 2017 I saw people
running and screaming it was very
similar in terms of the chaos it just
felt like things are feeling a little
bit in June 2017 three attackers
inspired by Isis killed eight people on
the bridge and surrounding area and
earlier that year a man drove a car onto
westminster bridge killing four people
than stabbing a police officer in the
past two years the country has not had a
major terrorist incident and only three
weeks ago the UK lowered its threat
level from severe to substantial
that threat level is still substantial
British authorities are now reviewing 74
cases of convicted terrorists released
from prison early this morning police
say one of them is back in custody
Anthony Roxana Saberi in London thank
you